men men
and more men this Glastonbury campers
settle into their temporary home with
Sir Elton Arctic Monkeys and Guns and
Roses backing all the best slots on the
pyramid stage is quite a bit at
Glastonbury to unpack for rappers Stef
London it comes down to women having to
work twice as hard to make it
I feel like women do get a harder time
like they critiqued a lot more like for
their body for their weight for their
you know what I'm saying put a lot more
I feel like Mel's get away with being a
little bit more basic women have to do a
little bit more as usual as we do in our
normal lives we have to do so much more
um but yeah that's that's the way it is
for now hopefully it'll change
Glastonbury co-organizer Emily Evis has
said the festival is looking to book two
female Headliners next year but it says
this situation has all come about
because of an industry pipeline problem
leading to a shortage of viable female
Headliners being developed
but according to the Lightning Seeds
front Manny and Brody it isn't the only
area the industry should look at with
streaming it's more about songs than it
is about albums and I think albums are
kind of what make big headline bands
it's almost like the Arctic Monkeys were
the last one through that gate almost
the Billy brag what's being sung matters
just as much as who's singing I you have
a song called sexuality so I've changed
the lyrics so it now says just because
you're they I won't turn you away if you
stick around I'm sure we can find the
right pronouns the trans Community need
cisgender people to stand up for them
for these Festival goers good music is
all that matters but to see a real
difference to who's on stage here the
industry needs to start dancing to the
same beat as those who are calling for
change Katie Spencer Sky News on worthy
Farm